tendez oui merci madame la présidente
cet amendement vise à supprimer les
dispositions relatives à la vérification
d'identité lors de la présentation du
futur passe vaccinale si la fraudeuse
ces documents sur ces documents doit
être sévèrement combattu et punis ces
dispositions viennent renforcer le
sentiment de défiance à l'égard des
français la pratique du contrôle
d'identité ou de la vérification de la
concordance d'identité est strictement
encadrée dans notre droit dans une
logique de protection des libertés
individuelles et repose principalement
sur les forces de l'ordre formés à cet
effet le régime de sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire actuellement en
vigueur ne justifie pas d'étendre cette
vérification
pour ces deux motifs il convient de
laisser cette tâche aux autorités dont
c'est le métier les forces de l'ordre
merci
on continue avec madame muller bran
défendu
on
continue avec madame d'après monsieur
fabien gay
merci madame la présidente monsieur vis
mes chers collègues on rentre dans un
moment important
sur la question du contrôle
nous l'avions dit sur la question du
passé ni terre nous avions redis notre
opposition et il y avait déjà la
question
d'y ajouter une pièce d'identité et nous
l'avions dit à cette époque là
nous pensons pas que tout le monde doit
contrôler tout le monde et que demain
nous devions non une société de contrôle
social
où chacune et chacun qui n'est pas
habilité à contrôler les papiers
puissent le faire c'est à dire nous
allons étendre que les serveurs à les
serveuses puisse contrôler les agents de
sécurité qui le soir même agent de
sécurité vont contrôler les serveuses et
les serveurs qui vont se rendre à un
événement ou à tel concert ou un tel
stade pour aller revoir une compétition
sportive on est franchement on nous ne
voulons pas mettre le doigt là dedans si
nous mettons le doigt là dedans nous
aurons les plus grandes difficultés pour
revenir en arrière donc une pensons et
nous continuons à penser qu'il faut que
ça soit les op j qui reste et qui puisse
contrôler y compris il ya un débat sur
quelle pièce d'identité parce
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas obligé de
présenter pièce d'identité avec photo y
compris
quelqu'un qui est avec vous peut
attester que c'est bien vous sur
l'honneur et ça fonctionne et si nous
mettons le doigt là dedans y compris
dans un doute raisonnable
je vous le dis en nous pensons dans une
autre société et ça ça nous permettra
pas de combattre efficacement le coc
vide c'est tout autre chose comme projet
de société qui nous est proposée par le
gouvernement donc nous proposons de
évidemment de supprimer ces alinéas je
vous remercie madame noël il est défendu
monsieur qu'elle n'avait
merci à madame la présidente de cheminée
shackley quelques beaux simplement pour
dire que ce débat dépasse bien sûr les
clivages politiques et puis suffit de se
rendre dans les établissements de
restauration pour se rendre compte
combien les tenanciers de ces
établissements ne souhaite pas
effectivement qu' il soit obligé
d'opérer des contrôles je crois que cela
relève de la responsabilité des forces
de l'ordre et la rédaction
tel qu'il a été prévu dans le texte
paraît suffisamment flou pour justement
pouvoir induire des abus et donc ceci
n'est pas acceptable et donc il convient
je crois de remettre les choses en place
c'est-à-dire de considérer que les
contrôles relève t reste de la
responsabilité des forces de l'ordre et
pas de celle des exploitantes
d'activités commerciales
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre sur collègues c'est un
amendement important qui est identique
avec beaucoup d'autres et qui vient bien
rappeler ce qu'est le pass sanitaire
dans son caractère
proportionné est temporaire quand
j'entends qu'un certain nombre de nos
collègues ont l'idée date d'insérer la
photo d'identité dans le passât ni terre
c'est bien qu'ils imaginent que ce pas
sanitaire durera longtemps parce que sur
un plan technique sans aucun avis de la
cnil allait proposer que la photo
d'identité intègre pas solitaire c'est
quasiment faire du pain salita en
lui-même une pièce d'identité et donc ça
c'est une grave erreur de mon point de
vue et nous ne devons pas
le passé l'été a déjà suffisamment
attentatoire aux libertés publiques j'ai
l'impression de me répéter mais c'est
bien ce que je pense pour que nous le
laissions au moins dans sa formule
actuelle y compris dans sa version pas
actional sidi si d'aventuré le parlement
devait voter ça mais de ne pas en
rajouter deux choses et sur la question
du contrôle de l'identité on va donner
cette faculté à des responsables
d'établissements mais non seulement on
va leur donner cette faculté au garden
est aussi eu un pouvoir d'appréciation
c'est quand ils se diront d'eux mêmes
que ils vont elles peut-être dans une
situation où ils vont devoir appeler à
justifier qu'il vous faire cette
démarche là or en france a été rappelé
très bien par plusieurs orateurs à
l'instant ce sont des personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
jouissant de prérogatives de puissance
publique forme est inscrit dans une
hiérarchie avec un pouvoir disciplinaire
voire debout vont s'exposer aux
sanctions de la justice qui font des
contrôles d'identité en france ils ont
un matricule sur le sur le sur le sur
l'épaule et si vous n'êtes pas contents
d'un contrôle d'identité en france vous
pouvez vous en plaindre et donc ça c'est
essentiel comment vous quelqu'un de
recourir et vous exercez demain
vis-à-vis d'un tenancier de bars ou des
restaurants qui vous empêchera de
rentrer donc vraiment supprimons ce
contrôle d'identité qui est une très
mauvaise idée mais ses soeurs
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai dit
hier tout à l'heure dans la discussion
générale
combien cette question était importante
pour notre groupe
nous avons dit qu'il était dans la
logique de l'obligation vaccinale
2e
respecter le pass
vaccinale en dépit du fait que nous
aurions préféré que notre amendement sur
l'obligation vaccinale fut adoptée
nous avons dit qu'il y avait pour nous
des conditions fortes en termes de
libertés publiques et c'est pourquoi je
ne vais pas développer mais l'argument
est très fort quand je vois qu'il est
dit que le restaurateur en question
devra statuer pour savoir s'il existe
des raisons sérieuses de penser
comment va-t-il penser en regardant le
visage l'apparence d'une personne qui
est là qu il va falloir quand même lui
demander ses papiers d'identité
cependant qu'une autre ne suscitera pas
la même suspicion il y a un gros
problème et je crois même un problème
constitutionnel
mes chers collègues j'ai observé que
monsieur le rapporteur philippe bas
avait été constant dans ses
appréciations et dans ses convictions
sur l'ensemble des sujets entre hier et
aujourd'hui sauf sur ce sujet ou son
appréciation à évoluer et j'espère de
tout coeur que ce lara que cela nous
permettra d'avoir une position très
claire sur la répartition des rôles
entre des commerçants restaurateurs etc
et les forces de police et de
gendarmerie que chacun accomplisse son
office monsieur benarroch
si mes collègues d'avoir brillamment
défendu ces amendements identiques est
similaire
cette mesure en elle même porte le
principe de contrôle d'identité réalisés
par des personnes non habilitées à le
faire et qui plus est qui ne souhaite
pas effectuer ce contrôle en leur
laissant plus libre appréciation à leur
discrétion totale des critères selon
lesquels ils pourraient ou pas contrôler
ses papiers cette mesure en fait
participe de fait à l'instauration d'un
contrôle social généralisé de la
population de l'installation d'un
nouveau modèle social et d'un nouveau
modèle de société qui est contraire aux
valeurs de beaucoup d'entre nous qui est
contraire aux valeurs de notre
démocratie et qui est contraire aussi
aux valeurs de notre groupe elf eu enfin
aussi nous ne l'avons pas dit par son
principe même par la façon dont la le
pouvoir discrétionnaire et donner à
certains qui ne le souhaitent pas
d'ailleurs conduire à des phénomènes de
violence de trouble de l'ordre public et
à un certain nombre d'incivilités qui
peuvent devenir assez grave donc nous
vous demandons sincèrement de bien
vouloir accepter de considérer les les
arguments des différents intervenants et
devient vouloir voter ces amendements de
telle façon à ce que nous n'allions pas
vers une dérive de notre constitution
l'amoureuse dernier il est défendu
madame benbassa
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministère collègues les règles
définissant le cadre d'un contrôle
d'identité sont établis par l'article
78-2 du code pénal seuls les officiers
agents et agentes rejoint de police
judiciaire peuvent le réaliser or la
viabilité du pass vaccinale dépend
grandement de son contrôle le texte
adopté par l'assemblée nationale
permettez d'octroyer aux personnes en
charge de ce contrôle le droit
d'effectuer non pas un contrôle
d'identité
mais je suis une vérification de
concordance documentaire si cette astuce
lexical n'a pas été conservé par la
commission des lois du sénat
le dispositif proposé par celle ci reste
tout de même problématique le texte
laisse toujours la possibilité aux
personnes chargées du contrôle du pass
vaccinale d'effectuer un contrôle
d'identité
ce transfert de compétence de la police
vers la société civile n'est pas
acceptable comment se prémunir de
possibles discriminations
comment éviter les abus volontaire ou
non de la part de ceux qui doivent
contrôler une grande majorité d'entre
eux n'est ni formés ni qualifiés pour
cela ajoutons à cela que l'astre est
chronophage d'un tel contrôle plus que
le simple scan d'un qr code peut rendre
ce contrôle d'identité difficile à
réaliser dans certains établissements
cette question du contrôle de l'identité
ne semble être qu'un détail dans le
débat pour le gouvernement cela ne l'est
pas pour beaucoup de nos concitoyennes
et concitoyens qui souffle
quotidiennement des abus liés à cette
procédure c'est aussi pour cela que je
demande sa suppression merci
[Musique]